jérôme seydoux n'était pas seul pour sa
conférence de presse à ses côtés le plus
parisien des italien silvio berlusconi
son adjoint silvio copie monsieur
valouse coni n'a pas eu beaucoup droit à
la parole mais avec ce sens de
l'expression propre aux milanais il a
décrit en trois images le style de cette
nouvelle télévision la télévision
laquelle nous sommes en train nous
commencions à penser c'est pas une
télévision en croco à col c'est un
télévision un spaghetti ce serait une
télévision beaujolais
champagne le samedi c'est à peu près
tout ce qu'a dit silvio berlusconi lors
de sa conférence de presse avec jérôme
seydoux il y aurait il déjà des
parasites sur les ondes franco italienne
pour le savoir il a fallu prendre un
rendez vous particulier avec monsieur
berlusconi apparemment la lune de miel
continue
fantastique je suis tombé amoureux de
monsieur ses idées il les
téléspectateurs français sont
certainement intéressés de savoir ce
qu'ils auront au moins le premier soir
oui je pense à une émission
à nous faites dans les plateaux il
missionne avec une cravate air
france est fabriqué en france fabriqué
avec des gens français mais si nous
trouvons pas les studios ici nous sommes
en train de rechercher
à paris au des autres pays en france
nous serons obligés de faire les choses
pour le démarrage en italie et le
présentateur de ses émissions il sera
français notre homme et cela
certainement français on dit que vous
avez beaucoup de candidatures déjà
séverin parmi nous espérons de
travailler avec des gens qui font la
télévision depuis longtemps et il faut
pour faire la télévision il faut avoir
des stars qui sont dans le coeur du
public nous essayons de les avoir du
storm antenne 2 de tf1 esther
côté on prend deux stars du cinéma et
qui
il avait travaillé en télévision pour la
première fois j'ai remarqué en italien
qu'on ne veut pas faire de commentaires
ont dit nos commun